a couple fun facts about the new Netflix
crime drama thriller the outsider the
lead role was actually supposed to
originally be played by Michael
Fassbender then he bailed and then Tom
Hardy was supposed to play the lead and
then he bailed so then we end up with
Jared Leto these are all big names and
it was exciting in the sense of okay
it's another Netflix or jewel movie with
a big star let's see if this can finally
produce so I'm gonna start with the pros
here the movie looks great the setting
in Japan is beautiful the cinematography
is all there it's lit great certain
angles they choose from different
perspectives of different characters
really works here so it was definitely
pleasing on the eyes for sure another
Pro here especially for a Netflix
original movie is that it had a
realistic tone it never went over the
top which a lot of movies do and you can
lose me real fast with that yes this
movie was a slow crawl but it still felt
ground in reality so I didn't feel like
I completely gave up on the movie
because of that I still felt like okay
this could have happened this is a vent
that makes sense now acting wise the
supporting actors here all around we're
great I thought they all did really good
here and sold it well and I thought the
man Jared Leto helped get out of the
prison was the star of this movie in the
sense of performance just in general
this movie did have a lot of potential
here it had peeks of interests it had a
good foundation but that's where I get
to the cons a number one con is Jared
Leto does not change his facial
expression for the whole movie it's
literally the same one the whole movie
and now my eyes are really watery doing
that so props to him for not getting
watery eyes I mean this was a male dim
performance by Jared Leto this guy won
an Oscar for Best Supporting Actor for a
way more challenging role in Dallas
buyers club this is maybe one of the
easiest roles you can get I think he had
maybe a hundred words of dialogue if
even come on try a little Jared Leto
something give the character some kind
of emotion or depth here I don't think I
can blame the writing totally there or
the directing because all the other
actors seem fine so Jared Leto was
really just bringing the ship down as
well the scene that angered me a lot was
a scene where Jared Leto cuts his
fingers off I mean wince a little bit
made it seem like cutting your fingers
off is a completely painless process
because even someone who has a really
high pain tolerance will still have some
kind of wincing and did we learn
anything about his character he
literally was a walking robot in this
movie you could have just had Jared Leto
on autopilot why did he even end up in
that prison why do we know nothing about
his time as a soldier and why do you not
want to be found so bad and killed the
former soldier in his unit that was just
strange to me give us some kind of hint
of what could have happened and made his
character the way he is that's what kept
my interest in this movie was that kind
of suspense like okay we're gonna find
out eventually what his deal is the big
reveal err oh this is why he's like this
we never got it just to tease it was a
trick like finish the script here if
you're gonna lure us into some kind of
idea a certain character you got to give
us a little more than that it's not a
real story we got to know another con
was the character of the sister here I
think she was literally just there to
giggle and look cute
she really was just like a pawn here
kind of creates some kind of tension and
drama and conflict in this movie which
really wasn't there because again you
didn't care about Jared Leto's character
he just wasn't interesting enough and if
I don't know more about him what can I
relate to and what he's thinking I don't
know anything about him it's like
watching literally a mannequin go
through these scenes or observing a
complete strangers life with no Intel
the movie was supposed to be set in the
1950s but was it just me or just didn't
feel like it I don't feel like really
any characters were directed that way
they all still felt like men 2018 Jared
Leto seemed like a man coming from the
future I don't think there was any
effort at all from a directing part of
getting his actors to get that vibe in
the feel the 1950s like if you told me
that took place in current time I
believe you my favorite line of dialogue
in this movie was you have a cute face
can I lick it that really was in the
movie you just watched a huge car and
was the ending it was just abrupt we put
two hours into this movie whose bland
dull no soul attending ends up with a
sister kills the traitor lost his best
friend just nothing job done moves on
with his life the end this really felt
like a student film in their freshman
year of film school had a good
foundation here I know I'm ragging on it
but it really did somehow keep my
interest the whole time like something
good was going to come but it didn't so
it just had a lot of missing pieces but
it wasn't awful it's not a terrible
movie but it's not good it's just there
it exists
you've seen movies like this before but
for Netflix original movies this isn't
as bad as they come because there have
been horrendous one so maybe it's a step
in the right direction but a baby step
so I'm gonna give this movie a five out
of ten definitely forgettable I don't
really suggest watching it but maybe
you'll find some good parts in it not
many but it had its moments please let
me know you saw the movie below I'd love
to hear what you have to say I respond
to everyone so please comment let's get
the discussion going please follow me at
Steve arleigh 1 on Twitter and Instagram
and please subscribe I review a bunch of
movies TV shows I do celebrity
interviews as well with the actors
themselves let me know anything you want
me to review as well make sure you do
that subscribe button and I'll see you
next time